thank you everyone for sticking here
Sunday afternoon late we all want to get
back home and enjoy the the what's left
of the weekend so I thank you for
staying here and I'm gonna talk about
Ruby this will move to language data
science was condom and the structure of
this talk is gonna be the following
first I'm going to introduce the concept
of the data science and what involves in
doing data science what do we why do we
care about multi language what what are
the requirements when we talk about
reproducibility then we're gonna see
what conde is and then specifically how
can the fates with all these other three
words that we've well that we've
introduced and finally I'm gonna give a
practical example of a library I've
worked on that's called topic here the
the link of my slide you can follow
along and so let's start with the first
term data science and and we're gonna
focus on what are the tasks tasks
involved in this field and if we look at
data science we can actually classify
the different tasks in four in four
areas the first one is the one I would
call like this a dark analysis kind of
like and your output in this a dark
analysis is it kind of some kind of
report some nice type of data cleaning
summarization of watching your data some
metrics some munching and cleaning and
some kind of data output then we have
this test that I call the main problem
is when you have to apply your data
science to solve a specific problem can
be a prediction problem a classification
are you kind of want to explore what's
in your data and the app and we're gonna
call that output a project or a model
then we have the task that I call like
algorithm development and that's where
you actually output a library or a
package and you're providing
functionality for these domain problems
right and that's like psych you learn in
Python alive
we're in Java or correct in our then in
data science we are also involved in
production right in making these models
available in production environments and
your output in that case is actually the
pipeline the architecture architecture
implementing that those libraries those
algorithms those the main problems in
your application and we can see things
like recommendation systems or fraud
detection and I said this is general
data science right but this paths are
not always done by the data scientist we
also find other other contributors other
team players that also are involved in
this data science tasks and I've named
them this way that there might be other
ways of naming them the first one is
data analyst we can also call this that
might be in this mainly this up ad hoc
analysis but sometimes may go into more
of the modeling problem too depending on
their skills then we have the title the
data scientist title and that's mainly
in this domain problem of solving
specifically problems in a specific
domain and giving a solution but
sometimes if the designers also might be
involved in the algorithm development of
those packages then in algorithm
development you can find traditional
software developers but also as we heard
in some of these talks previously you
also might need someone that's more
familiar with the math background right
in making sure that it's able to
implement those algorithms and I call
that computational scientist and then in
the area of production and development
you are you're gonna have involved
people that I actually understand the
architecture that are going to actually
develop and make sure that the
operations running and we call that
DevOps or architect so just three things
to keep in mind in this the data science
section that involves different tasks
may have different deliverables and
there are different contributors in
in in this area let's explore now
multi-language
and this is a survey from O'Reilly I
don't know if you can see it very well
that's survey that they did on data
science salary surveys and they asked
people that work in the field of data
science what are the most commonly used
tools in that there laughs and then you
can see the backgrounds mainly people
not only developers but also people in
like the data science business and then
you see a lot of Windows SQL excel or
the next Python Mac OS Java JavaScript
right so we see a lot of languages and a
lot of different tools being used what
if we kind of put those languages on top
of these tasks that we've previously
seen where do they fit where they're
actually what are the major languages
used in the different types of tests and
we say this first three which are the
three languages for example that Jupiter
has in its name
Giulia Python and R and those lines are
very hard to draw like every time I've
shown these slides of someone else
someone said oh you need to put like the
slide one millimeter
more to the left to the right that's
like that language is completely wrong
these can do everything right so this is
I have a disclaimer on the bottom saying
this is just my personal opinion
not based in any quantifiable way and
mainly of taking into account like the
maturity of the language how long has
been around like make it longer or and
mainly like what's the most common
common Earth's strongest area so as I've
said the these three languages python or
Julia are more we can see that our focus
on like this contributor that we've
called the data scientist right there's
something that that user is using and
then we can see python has gone more
into the way reach into the production
line because that we have a more variety
of different types of countries using
that language to
they will see we've seen that in the Big
Data space the the actual languages that
have evolved in the Hadoop world has
been Java right and in in those Java
architectures so that's what I've put in
in the context of data science this Java
language born into the production but
you see that the data scientist itself
the role of domain-specific problems is
more uses less this language compared to
maybe Python or R then we see those all
these new spark hype right with Scala
and and we see that they're mainly focus
on this algorithm development this
packages spark and the lip and it's
trying to get into the production it's
not yet there yet still but but it's
it's going right it's the new hire
people are starting to deploy try to
deploy this these things if they have
they're having their some of troubles
but they're trying to get there and we
see how another language ah where the
lists people that are more like
computational scientists they like this
SP languages right they're developing
their trying to push also this SP
languages into the data science field
and also into production with projects
like storm how about we have like one
left this our data analysts that we've
called they're mainly still focus on
Excel right and we have maybe some
adventurous the data analysts that are
more curious and say oh what's there to
it maybe those people go into north saw
SAS like commercial software or the
equivalent are and they're trying to get
those skills to not just do this ad hoc
analysis but also pushing to more the
domain projects the modeling part
multi-language what what what has
happened in data science regarding
multi-language well we see these
language agnostic applications like
we've seen Jupiter or conduct I'm not
gonna talk about and we'll see that all
these tools are also providing
multi-language interfaces it's important
to provide in the
so that your user that we've seen can
use a variety of languages chooses the
language of their choice so for example
bouquet provides a variety of interfaces
like our bouquet scallop okay Julia Lua
Python spark we can we also see that
provide spice Park interfaces etc so the
ideas from this section is data science
is multi language there's language
agnostic application being built and
it's important to have bindings and API
stew so that you use akin choose what's
what's like what language they want to
use let's talk now about reproducibility
so let's let's try to think a little bit
what are the requirements for us to
reproduce a big a science task and I've
come up with like these four simple
things first it might seem obvious but
you need to share your code right this
might seem obvious but the scientific
community actually has not that has it's
trying to do that right like there you
share your paper you not always share
your code so in order to reproduce the
first step share your code right and and
share it not only let not only the code
itself but other things like how what
random seeds you use how you initialize
variables etc then we have to control
versions right if the project was done
today would it like run two years from
now when maybe the project's finished
your your papers done someone wants to
use it and and that's not length not
only dependencies but the language
itself if I create a project right now
with Python to seven and I get it and
then I live it you know on my computer
and two years from now someone wants to
keep working on it
no we they need to know that that's the
version of Python I used then there's a
very interesting part of data in how we
version data and data in databases
change
how can we make sure that I can I can
reproduce exactly that output of that
model with that with the exact data
I used on the first time I presented my
result and then another question we have
to ask is this project or task a
platform specific have I built it just
for Mac OS have it build it for Linux
there a Windows option right so that I'm
not putting a restriction on the user on
what system they have to or if they do
have to but knowing that that's
important so what have people been doing
in the area of reproducibly well there's
a lot of people that have been doing
nothing right that's an easy thing to do
you do not think you don't get
reproducible anyway but it has a very
low overhead you don't do nothing then a
very another option is document what you
do and document and write down what what
you did and share that that's kind of
like the approach the research community
has had right you share a paper you
describe what was your method what
method you follow to get those results
and that's what you do on the other side
we've seen in more of like the
development world how we've started
creating these virtual machines and
start sharing images to get the exact
same thing but that has a very big
overhead how we've simplified that
overhead with creating containers and
with now the notes all the darker
movement but there's a sweet spot in the
middle that has lower overhead that was
what we call environments a lot of
people here might be familiar with using
things like beer to lamp so let's let's
kind of like compare isolation and an
overhead right like you do nothing you
were in like 0 0 right no over here no
isolation nothing we can document things
you still don't have any insulation
you're not provided nothing but you have
a little overhead you have to actually
write it down in the space of the the
VMS we see we have a
a lot of it elation but also a lot of
overhead a little less overhead and a
little less insulation if you use docker
and then we have like sweet spot of
Conda that's low overhead and provides a
pretty good insulation for your project
so another part of this reproducibility
is not you only not only have to track
those but you actually have to share
them so with we're all familiar with
sharing code and that's what github has
done right there's a reg repository
where you can access and download the
code there's a similar approach being
done with docker hub right you have a
container you push it push it into the
docker hub registry and and and you can
get that container what happens with
binary packages well we have we we've
had centralized repositories of packages
like you do pip install you download
from pipeline but there's also but
what's the alternative for a distributed
package repository or registry that's
what we call that's a project called bin
store that I'm also going to present and
I'm also going to pretend how we can
share those environments doing pin Star
Plus github so from this section just
like we need to meet certain
requirements to get reproducibility me
try to minimize our overhead and share
it now I'm going to introduce condom
condom is this language agnostic
cross-platform package and environment
manager that's written in Python we can
view the web pages
kondeh i/o and kenapa tidak dot org and
a lot of people have this confusion when
we talk about khandha how that's kind of
compare to anaconda - meaning Conda so
hopefully after this slide everyone like
sets these ideas clear so comments is
the package and environment manager
anaconda is Python a Python version
condom and a bunch of packages for
scientific and data analysis okay now
we've we found out that like anaconda
had a like a large overhead downloading
all those packages correct so we came
out well a lot of people can just manage
those packages as they want so we
actually don't need to provide a bunch
of packages with Conda they can just
download whatever they need so we have
like this mini Conda which it has very
low overhead just Python and condom it's
clear now okay another another question
that we get a lot it's like well how
this kind of compared to P and so I made
this table you know and I hope after
this table everyone also has the ideas
clear so as we've said Khan is language
agnostic so it doesn't have to be just
Python specific you can be you can build
kondeh packages for other languages for
the language itself so that's a big
difference with the ice I've set up Plus
virtual ends because Conda actually
handles environments natively you don't
need to use Conda and we're to a length
Conda already managed environments with
Conda F there's also the difference is
how the installation is done Khan
installs binaries and people compiles
from source and as we said because of
this language agnostic the environments
that you can manage with Conda are
actually general-purpose doesn't have to
be just Python environments but now it's
now the difference clear yeah okay so
another frequent question like oh can
you use Conda and pip well the answer is
yes you can con install pit and then
peope install whatever dependencies you
need to okay now it's kind of like gone
through each of these different terms
let's put them all together and kind of
analyze how we can do this so let's go
back to our task our schema our task
so when you start doing like this a Dirk
analysis what what's your what do you
need you need trains to be able to
install whatever package you're gonna
use to perform that analysis that report
that data cleaning so that's like
conduct install will do it for you when
you're working with like these domain
problems you want to have a way of
managing what are the dependencies then
you're using in just that specific
project you might have several multiple
projects you what I might switch from
one project to the other one and not and
and have like a way to isolate them and
that's where Conda amps can help you
then in the task of actually building
libraries and packages you need to build
them that's what kind of bill will help
you and when you're deploying to
architecture you might use a combination
of them to to help you out and as I seen
in the example that I'm going to show
next actually my process was just like a
black line that we see going from an ad
hoc analysis to a solving of the main
problem actually building a library and
then putting it into a production
deployment so as we seen how this
content is multi-language and you can be
packages that are or packages Python
packages or itself Python itself java
packages color etc let's view content
and reproducibility we've seen for four
different items before how we've managed
to use of share code code well we have
version control we have get well we also
have the ability to specify get hacks in
Condor builds how about version control
control of version so versions version
control so Conda provides yamo files
where you can specify multi-language
requirements so you can think of a
requirements txt but for multiple
languages then we have the problem of
data versioning
and Conda it just like you can add that
data in your condo package to with and
there's a couple of commands that can
help you
this data is still one of like the the
hardest problems because as data grows
you don't want to add it in any binary
package actually you want to have your
day to live somewhere else this is not
really there are several solutions like
like there's different alternatives
people in the database world have
managed how to keep track of the changes
in your database with with different
time stems and and fields in the
databases but still not like a unified
solution to it they're still problems
unlike how you manage data versioning
because you have to keep track of
whatever everything that has happened in
your in your data set then Conda can
help you because it actually its
platform you can build packages for
Lina's Linux OS X and Windows so first
thing how you get to Conda well you can
get it without as we said with anaconda
and all those which will also download
all these other scientific and data
analysis packages or just with mini
Conda a useful tip for people doing a
lot of setting up a lot of Linux
machines there's this w gate which
downloads the latest Linux 64 mini Conda
so as we said we can install packages
look install Python to seven we can
install scholar we can install databases
or document stores like MongoDB we can
install libraries pandas pockets Park
etc and this is the command uninstall
whatever you can include versions you've
won you if you don't you get the latest
stable version that's like the first
column of your schema of tasks is second
column more of like this environment
management well we've said there's an
environment llamo file with a
specification of what's the name of your
environment what are the different
dependencies that you want to that you
include you write your file you create
your environment with this command Conda
and create you activate the environment
source activate by data and you can list
all the packages that are included in
that environment which will also not
include just the ones that you specified
in your yellow file but all of the
dependencies of those packages too so I
can Duke on the list and get them or
also use another command s Condor and
export and if I want to have like a
freeze snapshot of all the versions that
environment I can use I can put it on a
file I usually call it free mo if I look
on the list I get this in like the
example I said I have dots because you
know there's a lot more if I do condom
export into a freezie mo I can get I get
the same structure with all the
dependencies and actually the bill num
double string 2 I can also list all the
environments that I have in my machine
content info skips gets me all the
environments that I have in my machine
ok we've gone from the second column
let's go to the third column that's like
the bill actually build packages to
build a package you need to build your
kind of recipe that usually usually a
meta yamo file and then build a sage or
feel bad this is from the examples of
the Condor documentation so this is an
example of a meta amo file you get the
package name the source attack URL
requirements for build and for run any
tests you wanna perform and any made up
data about the license or where you can
find information on the package
you can find a lot of more information
on the Manor llamo on the Condor
documentation then like if it's a very
simple package the building stage can be
just like set up the PI install for more
complex you can see examples there's a
repository of Condor recipes and you can
see a lot of examples on how different
packages or packages Java packages how
this build a sage my
be done and you can just copy now we've
built the package we actually want to
share it and that's I explained before
bin star right and I can do Khan I need
to count install this bin store logging
into my bean store account and then I
can upload this bill that I've already
done into my user user account and then
I can install that package do doing
can't install from my user my from my
repository in the name of the package
then we have this notion of channels
because as I said I uploaded to a
username to my user space right so that
way I can also I can have different
channels in my user space where I can
install a stable production deploy and
but also the latest staff build so I can
use Khan installed for example ok to get
the latest stable ok release but if im a
bulky developer and i want to test the
latest one and i can also install that
latest one the same way calling stall
and then just pass the channel with the
dev and I get that one these channels
can also be added into your environment
yellow file so for example here
imagine I'm working a project with
several people they're building their
own binary packages and I want to get
them from there so I just add their
their username and I'm going to separate
them over here I have errands and Ben's
channels and then I can download things
like are because I'm Erin build on our
package I can also download things like
notch because been built a notch package
same for SPARC and another interesting
things as we've said conda can can
interact with pip so if their packages
that are not condor pack they're not
Connor package for them you have two
options you can build your own condor
package or you can just like specify pip
and put the people the pip packages also
in your environment
now we're gonna see a practical example
of my project so this projects called
topic and a topic it was intended to be
topic modeling I had to do some topic
modeling on a project and I was using
Jensen which is a Python package for
topic modeling and and then I had to do
some visualizations and then I found out
that there was like I just saw on a
tweet that someone had built this cool
or Lda visualization and I think I don't
have it I have it here and I saw this
right and like you can see like the
terms of the different topics that you
find you can see how they're distributed
things like that and I thought oh that's
really cool but just an art an art
package right can I just like have us
why can I include it in my in my
property my data science project so this
is kind of the motivation behind
starting this project so as we said
before there's like a flow of my project
and of course all projects start with
some kind of hack right you put
something together you test it out and
it's kind of this like analysis you just
install things make sure right a couple
of scripts make sure they work and I
call that the hack then you you start
saying oh this starts me having some
type type of shape and when I call this
you know gonna actually make it a
project after the project was done and
saying oh well maybe there's people who
might benefit from packaging this into a
library and being able to reuse it so
that if you can just use topic and have
this like topic modeling class
visualization in their dataset and I
finally added this topic library in our
application called topic space so topic
mellowing very fast is a topic modeling
is a statistical model for discovering
topics in unli
both text data in large documents that
you have you want to see what those
talking some are about and you perform
Lda on them and then you get different
topics and how they're distributed in
different documents and the in your
corpus for more information on topic
modeling there's a good resource there
and here are the two packages I was
using so when you have a hack when I was
having a like when I started and had the
attack but just really like up to the
Python script that imported change them
and then this our script that like went
back for because it's a hack you really
you know you don't share it on github
because you're embarrassed that people
like think that's really bad code and
and blaming you for the rest of your
life and then you don't really care
about what versions you're using you
just like importing whatever it is
making sure it works
you don't worry about that's one
specific you don't know like even though
like your data somewhere it hard-coded
in your script probably then you say
okay let's go start getting serious and
you start okay let's wrapping things
into functions let add more
functionality you still have some
scripts because it's specific for your
domain problem in my case I was working
on documents on materials research then
I start creating you know importing this
kinda package is not just chancing but
others because I found that they had
better features or some better
performance in something that I cared
about I also added some pie pie packages
I imported those or packages and created
this environment game on file so now
yeah and and now I push things together
because they're cleaner and I have the
environment yet on file also checked
into github so I know specifically what
versions I'm using
Nana said ok after you know that was
success to successful for my application
my my problem I thought well maybe I
could just like you know do this or
Python library package it up so someone
else can also use it so then you start
worrying about generalization
wrapping things into classes have adding
up multiple back-end so it's not
CSV files but also added like
elasticsearch and solar readers they had
in order to be able to package into a
condor package I had to create kind of
packages of all those dependencies that
I had in pipe I also for all the other
packages that I needed and the
dependencies of all of those or packages
I then wrote my Conda recipe and did
Conda build and uploaded my topic model
into my user my account in bin star so
now we we have things to get help we're
version we're controlling our versions
we have different different packages for
different platforms but our data still
this like um it's not tracked anywhere
right because it's not specific for this
library at the end the end fourth column
in our process it's the application and
in our application that we call topic
space we just added topic as a
dependency in our environment demo file
and and that's and then include any
topic code that you want in that
application that's a flask app and the
only problem there you still see data in
yellow you know you can pass it as
environment variable it's still not
there's not an ideal way of how you keep
track that that data it's up still up to
the developer to manage how you share
how you read the data where you read it
from how your you're passing it and
things like that but we've come a long
way from being able to reproduce things
from when we started so that's I can
show you the actual topic it's here you
can see the environment yamo file that I
started with with the project you can
see the condor recipe with a different
or packages and that was it i also
wanted to mention that that we all think
we
we it's the end of this conference we've
had all like a great weekend I hope but
in the other you know other parts of the
world people are having a very hard time
so we should just be thankful for being
here being having each other being able
to like thank the organizers and all the
speakers that have prepared slides for
us and and everyone who you've enjoyed
having this weekend I think it's
important that we realize and be
thankful for what we've got and any
questions
that's it's taken care of
like you just you can just add what you
think you need and Conda is going to
download those packages and all the
dependencies of those packages does a
package solving for you
right so sorry I forgot to like repeat
the first question the second question
is like is the MongoDB the actual
database or the Python package for it
and it's actually the the database so I
can have an example here so I think I
had it here MongoDB so if I do
[ __ ] D data pass data
DB DB pad it starts MongoDB in this PI
data one example so so like this mongrel
lives in like this environment so if I
get like if I'm out of this environment
like it's not so if I get out like it's
not so if I do source deactivate
there's no [ __ ] DB here yeah so the
coning site we have a condom centralized
repository so he can come from there or
you can build your own package in your
for example bin store so I think that is
the I think the recipe we can look for
the recipe in other kind of recipes so
on the recipes here there's a lot of
recipes on how those packages are
created in the first first place I think
yeah so
here's the MongoDB and here's how the
meta llamo and the Builder sage on how
it builds the package yeah
so usually the question is like how you
move it from minister suit to a
centralized conduit to a centralized
Condor repository correct so the answer
is right now the Condor central
repository is managed by a continuum and
usually what happens if we notice or
there's a demand sometimes it's just
like a tweet someone asks hey I'm using
you know we like to have this package
available in the Conda central
repository it actually gets push if it's
related to you know scientific computing
and data science the things of having
distributed systems is that distributing
repository is that you still you're
gonna get it the same way right like
from your channel you can you can get it
and so you can tell your user just to
like it should like - see and your
username the difference for your user so
you can always use that
so the in continuum so if you go to the
Anaconda here you can see all the
different licenses for the different
packages available through the condor
central repository in in your user in
your own user and mainly of them are all
PhD MIT there's a couple of GPL
but you manage that in your own user
account on being stored like you can
upload like you specify if you go to pin
store that you manage that yourself and
you can find I don't know you know if I
look for spark and can see all the spark
spark projects and then I can find here
what the license for that so you can add
the license in your meta llamo file and
so it will show to the users the user
know what what license that package has
so the question is if you have something
that's not a kind of package and you
want to install it in your environment
so for for example right now for things
like things in pi PI you have the PIP
way of specifying things
so it shouldn't be like hard to add our
Condor package of the that information
so that of not being you don't have to
do like the entire package but a way of
specifying that the building and Conda
package for that ODBC driver and then
adding it in your mo file the same way
you add kind of packages so I would say
that's the way the way to go yeah yeah
so you can also when you do content you
can do con the install of thing of
things that are not even in bin store
that are just on your local of fascist
any other questions
Yeah right yeah so that's that's
actually so the question is like if you
invert in Pippen BLM when you are create
a virtual environment you can have the
option of not downloading numpy but
getting it from the default and that's
like the default behavior of Condon
vironment so you never actually install
again in your in that new environment
option it always comes from the default
one
so the download does doesn't happen it
okay well thank you